[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
is a TV and radio journalist host of two
hugely successful podcast common sense
in hardcore history and a self-described
political Martian Dan Carlin welcome to
the Reuben Ripple thank you for having
me on political Martian I love this
phrase I understand why you use this
phrase but tell the people who don't
know what a political Martian is what is
it it came from not being able to have a
good easy description when people ask
you your political views I'm really
jealous of the people that can throw a
word out there and everybody goes okay I
get where you're from I don't have
anything like that
so I tried to figure out how you in a
very nice short way describe that you're
kind of off the map and that was what I
came up with just this idea that listen
I'm from Mars as far as you're concerned
because no word I mean I would have to
sit there and go well I'm a little bit
this when you start to give them sort of
a political recipe 30% to 20% and just
political Martian ends up people can nod
their head and say okay I get it you're
off the grid somehow yeah and some of it
is also that you're actively trying to
figure out things still right like we
have this thing in America where
everyone seems to believe or want
everyone else to believe that they know
everything you don't come from that
position well it's a combination of that
and believing that you have and this is
not you know I'm not insulting I help
people who have ideologies but this idea
that you could have a template that
works all the time is something that
just doesn't appeal to me because I
think you have to be able to pivot based
on circumstances you have to be able to
to admit that something's not working
but if that conflicts with your ideology
how do you reconcile both if you have to
be able to learn based on what you're
actually seeing and I felt like there's
not a whole lot of flexibility sometimes
in these ideologies yeah what percentage
of people do you think actually
understand political ideologies in
general that's what I was sort of
talking about at the top of the show but
it's like I feel like people don't
really understand what really is the
difference between a liberal and a
progressive or a libertarian and a
conservative reading of stuff like do
you think most people even that talk
about politics professionally actually
under
stand sort of the the philosophic
underpinnings of the stuff well the easy
answer that is no but the second answer
is partly because those words have all
changed in terms of meaning I mean take
take take liberal as a perfect example I
think I'm a liberal I think you're a
liberal I think most people in this
country who favor a democratic form of
government based on freedom and rights
and civic action and all that that we're
all liberals in the grand scheme of
things you know you have to kind of sit
down with people and dive deeply into
what they believe to try to figure out
you know where they stand but but on the
spectrum of governments all around the
world throughout all time trees we're
all liberals right right so we're just
arguing over you know what percentage of
this is that you want to you want to put
into the category but so by not knowing
what the words really mean or by
conflating what they mean or changing
what they mean I the reason people use
progressive is because liberals been so
changed in terms of its meaning I don't
think any of these terms what is
conservative mean I mean I'm fiscally
conservative what does that mean right
it doesn't mean anything any know that
as I've done this show at least in this
car incarnation for last two years I've
realized I use these labels because
sometimes you need them to frame
conversations and yet the more we use
them the more meaningless they become
which is a straight I guess I'm a
political Martian well and the thing is
is that is that if you sit down and try
to figure out when you're talking to
people where you stand on this issue or
where you stand on that issue I always
feel like we're all a mix of that if you
think you're really up and down the line
give me a little time and I'll figure
out I always say we're all radical on
something you know I'll find some
subject where you know you said that you
felt that way about it and gave no sort
of clarifying remark people would be
like look I think I think that describes
all of it I think we feel like we have
to I remember learning about totems in
like psychology 101 and I think that's
what a lot of people do where they sit
there and say part of my self-image is
that I'm a conservative or that I'm a
liberal and that locks you into things I
mean to be able to say that I base my
opinion on my own views and that I don't
have to fit into any particular box I
find that completely liberating I mean
people will say that you're inconsistent
that's where they'll turn well you're
really not going to say you don't have a
consistent philosophy
I'm not sure why I have to have a
consistent too long right why should we
treat a political philosophy like a
religion that's actually the reverse of
how we should treat it and yet they seem
to want this purity test and what a
great line I mean I love that line I
think it was on complicitous ed I think
it may have been a Cain's who said you
know that somebody accused him of
flip-flopping so we would call it
flip-flopping guy and he said when the
facts change I changed my mind what do
you do yeah you know and that's kind of
how I feel I mean I'm not going to get
locked into I know that I tend to be in
my own life certain ways but if I'm a
fiscal conservative for example which I
am and you find out that for this
particular cause you need to spend a lot
of money if I determine the cause is
worth it I'm going to spend a lot of
money does that mean I'm a flip-flopper
right so I mean in that sense I guess
I'm more of a pragmatist but but even a
pragmatist
can be utopian in ways you could say
okay I want to base things on what's
likely to work at the same time I want
to shoot so better than we have now does
that make you a pragmatic utopianist I
mean do those words and once you start
to mix those phrases do they mean
anything anyway I'm a liberal
conservative I'm a I'm a conservative
liberal I'm a pragmatic utopias what are
these a lot of I like premeditated
spontaneity I mean it just does it not
make any sense anymore yeah how
frustrating to some of that get for you
as someone that tries to bring some of
these ideas up that you have to talk
about things sort of in a way that
sometimes can be a little you know
confusing even for you what's
frustrating in traditional media because
they they demand it yeah that I do that
which is why I was always fighting with
people and in the world that we're in
now in new media it's not frustrating at
all I could be anywhere I want which is
why I'm a political Martian and no one
says anything they're fine with it which
is you know to me that's a sign of the
changing maybe state of things although
it also might be a sign that I don't
have a lot of liberal or conservative
listeners yeah I don't have to be one of
the other have a lot of political
Martians listening yeah I think it's
probably a little bit little bit less
tell me a little bit about your time in
the more mainstream media and what led
you to say I'm going to go off the range
here and see if I can figure this out on
my own which you've obviously been very
success I never wanted to do I didn't I
didn't know I was working here in town
at the ABC station
and I was working on the assignment desk
and I thought you know I was about 23
and I thought I had it made I thought
this was really good and these reporters
would come in who are only a little bit
older than I was and so what are you
doing to get out of here I said not a
lot of this is greatness all know you'll
die here you know you'll be doing this
forever
um and so to sort of swage them I sent
out tapes to be a reporter and no one
was getting hired and so I didn't think
there was any real danger and then I got
hired um I became a television reporter
and then as life has it you know
opportunities intervene and then someone
gave me a talk radio show job and I was
doing three hours a day five days a week
and that's where I think things really
started to grow and change because you
know and I'm always uh we feel bad for
the people that are getting started
today because I got to make all my
egregious mistakes and have all that
stuff go out into the ether and be gone
if I started today those would all be
some YouTube video all put together and
they see every gasps and horrible thing
I ever said are made yeah that shouldn't
be understated right well your thought
out there because I think that's a huge
thing and I mentioned it I had Dennis
Prager on a few weeks ago and I said to
him you know now that you're in the
digital world you come from traditional
media and radio but how conscious are
you of being afraid of saying something
that can just be selectively edited or
clipped in a way that's going to make
you seem like you said the reverse thing
and then just be relentlessly attacked
for that and the fact that you were able
to have the breeding ground before it
was fully on the the the I guess the
infinity grid of existing forever micro
ESRI digital stone a yellow stone as
long as there is this thing those things
will be out there now now that I'm now
that I've got most I hope of the
egregious mistakes out of the way mom I
like that it's digital stuff yeah I like
the idea that's never going away but it
but the kids coming up today who have to
make all their mistakes and have it be
forever available I'm sympathetic I'm
glad I didn't exist in that era I'm glad
I was able to get all of my nonsense out
of the way before it was forever but
yeah I mean so in terms of my career
that's how you learn and and and then
also the political Martian thing works
itself out that way too because in talk
radio when I was there as I think it
still is it's really a
the medium and you know you would have a
conservative guide and you'd have me and
then you'd have another conservative guy
and I was the one that was continually I
mean I was at odds with the audience
all the time and I was about 26 and the
average age of talk radio was about 35
to 45 and so I mean I it was a it was a
baptism by fire that looking back on it
now was really good for me at the time
it was really hard but I mean that's how
life is for everybody I mean you know as
you're working your career out you have
these ages where you're just pulling
your hair out sometimes and now you look
back on it and it's a wonderful learning
experience at the time not knowing the
future you know it's uh as I think
especially for guys in your 20s when you
really are in a place where you want to
you know uh your self-image is so
wrapped up in how you and gosh it was
such a hard time period and now I look
back on it and think though if you don't
go through that you're not where you are
now and so um you know when you give
your kids advice as a parent there's
going to be a lot of that I'm going to
throw them and hope it sticks yeah of
course they're going to have that
digital would you call it the do digital
stone digital stone their their stuff
can all be eckstein digital and they
also whether you how to cut it off to
the hand they don't want to hear
anything dad has to say anyway so I'm
not sure you can teach your kids a lot
sometimes yeah I'm Kerry so you're the
you were the sort of liberal or Martian
Martian around a lot of conservative
radio what do you think it is about
conservatives that it's only
conservatives that listen to radio
basically I mean we know that liberal
channels air America and any of the
progressive stuff yeah I guess some of
it exists here and there but it pretty
much always fails or nobody listens is
there something about conservatives and
talk do you think it's a good question
uh and first of all I always had a
libertarian bent which allowed me a
place where there could be a meeting of
the minds between the audience if you
talk about freedom and liberty in the
Constitution which I do there was a
place where we could have some
commonalities and then work around it
in terms of liberal is because I believe
in things like social programs and
things like that so there were areas
where where we could have a little a
little friendly competition but but they
were meeting of the minds areas in terms
of why um you know Rush Limbaugh he
always likes to say that there will be a
way
of the talk-radio history library and
he's right and he will own that but by
but by changing the landscape you know I
can't speak for other mediums I can
definitely talk about radio it's not
extremely inventive they're not
extremely chance takers you know they
does and so when you see something
working I think Limbaugh actually said
this he said for years they told me to
be like someone else and not to do this
and then the minute he makes it then
then they just want you to be like him
yeah I think that was partly my problem
too when I would go in there and say why
do you want me to be like all these
other people they would say because
that's what works look at what's working
everywhere so I think there's this
attitude that look I guess what I'm
saying is if a liberal talk show host
made it big somewhere then you would see
everybody saying well listen this is
working in Boston you should try them so
I think there's a tendency to follow the
leader in that business and I think he
started off the trend after the Fairness
Doctrine added them if you go listen to
talk radio before Limbaugh it's a
completely different animal I mean I
remember listening to it as a kid and it
said it doesn't bear any resemblance
what we have today so once you see that
working that becomes the template and if
you want to be big you need to do it
that way so that's why I had such a hard
time for 12 years in the medium I wasn't
like that do you remember a guy by the
name of Bob Grant your big radio I
remember being in the car with my mom
when I was 12 13 something like that my
mom hated this guy did not ever agree
with him on anything
his callers would call in he would just
scream at them and then they'd hang up
and it was it was just chaos and I
remember thinking I'm who could listen
to this kind of chaos and yet he was one
of the biggest guys most active guy
named Joe pine who was the original and
there was a lot of imitators but Joe
pine was I want to say you go back to
like 1970 and pine actually had a TV
show too and it was the first one where
you would just because before that it
was like the dick Cavett's and everybody
you know in the William F Buckley and
they were cigarettes and black and white
high money and Joe pine would just say
you're a communist and not yell at him
and and you know what's funny is is that
when these are novelties it's
interesting yeah but when it becomes the
norm it I mean I was I was talking to
somebody the other day we were talking
about what I heard a right-wing
talk-show host say the other day and I
know he doesn't believe that but he's
got to differentiate himself from the
competition
so for example we're talking about a
riot in Berkeley and it was who could be
the hardest on the rioters and this guy
said they ought to be taken out by the
police put in the back room and
euthanize like animals and you go well
why would he say that well he says that
because he's got to differentiate
himself from the competition who said
the toughest thing
I mean this guy's going to go vacation
at his house in the Hamptons after he
said this meanwhile he's ginned up the
anger level in the country so much why
not now there's not a lot of individual
responsibility because no individual is
responsible for all of that sure but
collectively it's creating a situation
where there's no countervailing forces I
mean if you're ginning up the anger on
this side what's reducing the anger on
that side what what's helping us achieve
some sort of stasis and the answer is
nothing yeah well I think the answer
might be maybe if I could be so bold it
would be a little bit of people like us
people that like us who are a little out
of the system right we're out of the
mainstream system but we're trying to
find some answers so you get the the
flamethrowers saying crazy things like
that I was you know talking about the
protesters myself but I'm certainly not
for euthanizing them but that people
like us who actually try to explore some
of these ideas are maybe the
counterbalance now so I guess some of
the same people are listening know that
that's an inherent problem I guess but I
think we're getting some of them right
because we know this because the cable
news and mainstream news their numbers
keep going down and digital stuff keeps
rising so we must be shifting some of
those people over right I should suggest
that maybe it's a genre playing itself
out you know that's the other problem
going into death Road yeah and I think
what happens is naturally you take it
more and more extreme right because when
you're nice it's it's a little like a
drug situation where you need more and
more to get the same effect but at a
certain point you overdose and die right
no matter how strong you are and I think
when you're talking about euthanizing
protesters in the back room there's not
much further you can go right and so
maybe what happens at that point is the
genre and the medium and the style plays
out and it's cyclical I mean I think you
could say that again like like cutting
off your heroin supply for a while and
going back I mean it may come back
another round but I'm not sure what
these people can do to continually gin
up the level of anger so that those
people are still
getting something out of the program I
mean I find this in my own political
show where after a while you think at
least I think it's getting repetitive
now what do you do if you've already
said everything that you think and I'm
not willing to say stuff I don't believe
I'm not willing to to take it to the
next level to keep the Harrow and hit
you know affecting you the way you want
it to
at what point you say okay I've said
everything I could say you either take
this or leave it but I'm not going to
continue to hammer this point home I
don't need to I'll do something else
yeah I'm not sure everyone has that
freedom and I know that those people are
being told by consultants on these talk
stations more having your heat heat heat
um so what do you do in those moments
where you felt I've said this already
this I've made this case I've talked
about this for a couple months or maybe
a couple years and you want a shift how
do you actually do you tell your
audience or I guess oh yeah oh yeah
we're going I've always been very very
open with them about my struggles but
partly is you try to find different ways
to to look at the point from different
angles I mean that's what I think you
know media with with radio especially
they used to say that because people are
getting in and out of their cars for
example all the time you can't go any
deeper than 15 minutes right because
otherwise you know you can't assume that
people are following you through this
whole broadcast I mean they you say I
they have to know where you stand on
every single issue within five minutes
of turning on the radio I'd rather the
cartoon character yeah yes the cartoon
Phil I said to them that's not going to
happen now on on my program and on your
program you can show shades of grey and
nuanced and especially because that's
actually novel now now that might play
out the same way that the right-wing
stuff is playing out but but the novelty
of being able to say everything is a
little bit more complex than you make it
out to be is great but I've done more
than 300 comments on shows and I start
running our not creative enough to
continually come out with new ways to do
that at least not to my satisfaction the
audience says they still want to hear
more of this stuff but I'm not sure I
want to give it to them that to me seems
too much like what I got away from this
is the true artists struggle I don't
know if you think about it in those
terms but really this is the struggle in
arts to create something successful
you're examined and then still feel
enough inner power to continue and not
pander and make something near and all
that it
shows you've really thought about it
because it's exactly right and it's
something that I didn't get initially I
had to I had to learn it by slowly but
surely first of all getting used to the
idea that anything you're doing is art
is weird because you can't call yourself
an artist artists is something that the
other people have to say yeah and and
first of all I don't think that anything
that we do politically is art and that's
part of the problem because now the
other podcast that I'm doing has evolved
into something that is a little a little
bit like art any yeah and it's so
satisfying to be able to do something
where you stand back and you look at it
you go
I'd like my grandchildren to hear that
because if I die before they meet me
they'll get a chance to know me through
this whereas the more I listen to the
political stuff even my own stuff um
there's I don't see any art in it and
once you've done some painting if you
will the idea of going and doing my pool
cleaning job is just not as not as
satisfying and and at a certain point
I'm tired of it I mean I think we live
in a country that's a representative
democracy which requires us to be
engaged but you because of what you do
are hyper engaged I'm I per engaged at a
certain point and this is why I didn't
do 12 straight years to talk with you
because you burn out and especially in
my case and you and I talked about this
earlier I mean I'm a guy who feels like
I rubbed the magic lamp and the genie
came out and said you have a wish what
is it I said I want a political outsider
because these politicians are killing us
and he gave me Donald Trump and I
thought oh I really should have had a
lawyer with me to decide exactly how I
wanted to phrase that wish right um and
but what that does in my particular case
is I'm not sure what to do anymore
because I got what I asked for for I've
been doing this 20 for 25 years if you
had my radio thing I never thought I'd
get a political outsider now I have one
and look what I got so what do I tell my
audience now where do I go from here
[Music]
you
[Music]